una decisión histórica en un régimen
teocrático el fiscal general de Irán
anunció el fin de la policía de la moral
la policía de la moral no tiene nada que
ver con el poder judicial y ha sido
abolidada Por quienes la crearon
un intento por sofocar tres meses de
protestas dentro y fuera del país que
dejan al menos 450 fallecidos luego de
la muerte de la joven kurda masa mini
bajo custodia de esa fuerza por no
portar bien el
Irán también anunció que revisa la ley
que desde 1983 exige que las mujeres
porten el velo y sin dar detalles el
presidente ebrahim Racing habló de
flexibilidad en la implementación de la
Constitución
los fundamentos islámicos y republicanos
dirán están arraigados
constitucionalmente pero existen métodos
para implementar la Constitución que
pueden ser flexibles
Según la ley a partir de los 7 años las
niñas deben usar el jiyab y todas las
mujeres desde la pubertad deben cubrirse
la cabeza y llevar ropa holgada en
público la policía de la moral
patrullaba las calles de Irán desde 2006
para hacer cumplir el código de
vestimenta Y aunque fue reformada en
2016 ilimitada a reportar infracciones
sin tomar decisiones definitivas ni
castigos en septiembre este año más a
mini fue arrestada y golpeada lo que
según grupos de derechos provocó su
muerte tres días después en un hospital
de Teherán dejando en evidencia casos de
violencia similares pese a los recientes
anuncios los manifestantes convocaron
para el lunes una huelga de tres días
con el objetivo de mantener la presión
sobre el régimen de los ayatolas